c4 c4 babyyyy
[Music]
one more there right there come on
someone someone's gonna go in this house
whether they like it or not come on come
on come on you can you can do it okay
shenanigans are happening
I'm starting to think no one's gonna
come to my birthday party but I got the
candle right here anybody hmm still
having a birthday party anybody that
wants to come by mmm well still in the
circle technically top ten and I've been
in the same goddamn building this whole
time waiting for people to come to my
goddamn birthday party that's just rude
last weird top five and I'm just sitting
here I've been sitting here this old
goddamn game [ __ ] of course I'm not
gonna let it go down like this I'm not
gonna let it go down like this I'm top
three and I've been sitting in a [ __ ]
house for the whole goddamn game someone
is getting blown up with these
explosives oh my god it's just me and
another dude no it's just me and them Oh
such a [ __ ] thing to do I didn't ask for
this
I just wanted to blow someone up I just
wanted to blow someone up I've said that
someone is gonna get blown up maybe c4
there's only two people left in the game
everyone knows what I have to do I go
down of my own accord
I think they're just stuck in disbelief
what the [ __ ] just happened
[Laughter]
and frankly I don't blame them